first some myth busting
Moon sinking is not a thing it's such a
compelling idea the idea that menstrual
cycles sync up with the cyclical waxing
and waning of the Moon much like the
ocean tides the moon cycle is 29.5 days
but in 2019 an analysis of 7.5 million
menstrual cycles from 1.5 million women
around the world found no relationship
at all another commonly held view is
that when people live together their
periods sync up humans love to find
patterns and a certain amount of overlap
is to be expected but actual sinking of
Cycles is not backed by data the
textbook idea of a 28-day cycle is a bit
of a myth too a normal cycle can be
anything up to seven days longer or
shorter than this everyone is in